et pour en parler quelques scènes aussi
président de l'institut international de
gestion des conflits
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france la coalition des
groupes rebelles à l'offensive depuis
une semaine contre le gouvernement
centrafricain a rompu aujourd'hui son
cessez le feu qui a tourné court
quelles conséquences la petite avoir sur
l'élection présidentielle et
législatives qui doivent se tenir ce
dimanche
je pense que c'est regrettable cette
rupture est la conséquence elle n'est
pas nouvelle elle a déjà commencé
c'est toute la tentative des groupes
rebelles et de certains acteurs
politiques de ne pas aller aux élections
et donc on s'attend à ce que l'élection
soit chahutée de par le droit et que les
électeurs puissent avoir des difficultés
pour accéder aux yeux mais je pense
qu'avec tout ce qu'on voit se déployer
avec l'appui des partenaires
internationaux
les élections auront bel et bien lieu
mais il n'empêche que la préoccupation
majeure est ceci dit comment les choses
vont se passer après parce qu'il ya eu
un temps pour la paix qui a pas de
concession avec cette structure et cette
réduction de la violence et il est à
craindre que des violences plus continué
même après les élections et saper tout
le travail qui est fait et c'est l'une
des premières d'occupation que nous
avons joué justement est ce que l'on
doit s'attendre avant la tenue de ces
élections
dimanche à un embrasement dans le pays
est ce que même l'élection va pouvoir se
tenir
je pense que dans le cas sont africains
quand on suit bien ce qui se passe la
question n'est pas ce qu'on doit faire
et ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut
faire en centrafrique c'est forcément
aller aux élections parce qu'avec tout
ce qui se passe on peut se dire que bien
évidemment qu'il n'y a pas la sécurité
par tour il faut reporter les élections
mais vous connaissez bien ce pays c'est
que depuis des mois il ya des acteurs
qui veut pas les élections qui veut de
la transition
parce que certains poids que c'est de
pouvoir c'est la transition qui est la
voie d'accès au pouvoir
or un pays comme la centrafique qui
renaît de ses cendres a besoin de
consolider sa démocratie même si on
n'est pas solides atouts par endroits et
donc nous pensons qu effectivement il
faut aller aux élections
ces élections vont se tenir et il faut
tout faire pour
tiens mais en même temps il faut
poursuivre cette politique de
pacification
avec cette crise armée donc je rappelle
nappe n'est pas ce qui reprend les armes
aujourd'hui ont signé l'accord de
quartier mais aujourd'hui tourner le dos
à cet accord un point important aussi
sur lesquels je voudrais insister c'est
que tous les acteurs politiques
centrafricains qu'il soit pour opposer
aux plaisirs et chaînes tous les
démocrates doivent signer pour faire
obstacle à la violence
parce qu'il vaut mieux avoir un
adversaire politique avec lequel on
n'est pas d'accord sur des orientations
politiques je suis la manière de piloter
le projet le pays plutôt que du plan d
armes et voilà pourquoi nous pensons que
au delà de toutes ces difficultés il est
un point bas soit il est fondamental
d'aller aux élections et que cette
région la plus aider à consolider tous
les efforts faits depuis quatre ans cinq
ans aujourd'hui en centrafrique
pourquoi cette coalition de groupes
rebelles a tourné le dos à l'accord de
cartoon vous savez l accord de paix avec
khartoum était un bon accord
nous l'avons analysé de près mon budget
hackers s'en sont mêlés et pour faire en
sorte qu'on peut savoir un accord
crédible et n'empêcheront quand il ya
guerre il ya des gens qui ont des
intérêts haute
certains ont signé cet accord mais je
pense que sans une adhésion totale
et puis vous savez quand il ya conflit a
des intérêts visibles et invisibles qui
brûlent des fois le jeu et la plupart de
cette nous posons dit qu'ils se
retournent contre l'accord c'est des
gens qui veulent défendre un peu les
intérêts mais il ya aussi ces quinze
acteurs politiques ce témoin qui veut se
jouer sur ça et nous n'avons pas oublié
que d'encore look simple rixe d'arrière
accusé d'avoir fomenté cet univers de
rébellion ce qui est une accusation
grave et une accusation qui ne servent
pas la démocratie et donc beaucoup
d'acteurs pense qu'avec les élections il
ne peut pas que c'est de pouvoir et
c'est pas les armes pour la condition
qu'ils peuvent assez de pouvoirs dont
nous pensons que c'est ça qui fait
vraiment au delà des oppositions que les
gens peuvent avoir avec le président
actuellement à l'exercice mais c'est
surtout la lapel l'appât du gain pardon
qui fait que beaucoup de ces clowns ne
veut pas laisser leur avantage et donc
veulent ce service des voies des
incompréhensions ou des divergences
politiques qu'elles ont pour reprendre
la guerre justement donc le camp
touadéra accuse françois bozizé
ancien président et principal adversaire
du président sortant de profiter de
l'instabilité qui règne dans le pays
pour préparer un coup d'état est ce que
ces accusations sont fondées selon vous
je pense que il faut sur le film
la candidature de françois bazinet a été
invalidée il est remonté donc à boussens
poids et donc l'accusation du
gouvernement je ne pense pas que
l'opération trafic 1 va accuser l'ancien
président de manière légère faut pas
oublier que toi tu irais rentré
clandestinement en centrafrique le
prison doit dire à certains de ses
conseils il avait même conseillé de
faire en tout pour que la loi soit
appliquée que l'onu puisse donc lancé le
mandat d'arrêt mais l'a pas fait et donc
aujourd'hui nous pensons que s'il ya une
accusation entière protection contre
l'eau vers mars en profite car il est
partout internationaux ont des parents
jackie chan part de cette accusation et
c'est grave et triste pour la démocratie
centrafricaine merci beaucoup pour tout
ces précisions qu'axa nous si je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'institut international de gestion des
conflits merci à vous